oh mama don't like you she exit three be
like I'm trying we're trying to dice I
hope you guys are all doing well we're
on our way to Disney we have a hot
Disney date
what time is Disney close that's a good
question it's at 7:00 I'm gonna turn
park hours 8 a.m. to 11 p.m. in downtown
Disney is till - I am
oh I'm weird I'm staying there on all
night time now is 342 what's our eta
never along 504 I just keeps going up no
we're gonna go to dinner that the
biggest problem
oh I'm robitussin oh it's just me myself
and I so bad till I die cuz I got me for
life
oh I don't need I forgot already get an
interval that is go look at that fire in
my soul oh my gosh I'm going 30 miles
per hour this is a record
Wow Dean oh wow and news a song with our
face chat to Jimmy
it says mom on Twitter what I like it no
look Bob look look at not hot not lock
it up look and lager longer longer arm
only one : we need a bike I love this
who is this to be remixed like a nice
remix maybe there is one I haven't
looked
I'll look if you like one
seven years don't you're sure the mama
told me go make yourself some friends or
you'll be lonely once I was seven years
old I'm on this lull in such a big news
about how Matty didn't see any like
Samir's get me the puppy
let's not chat me that puppy chick girl
possibile so I feel I need you I need
you I need you right now what I need you
right now don't let me don't let me
don't let me down don't let me wear me
down don't let me down
alright let's just try now I'm bored
thank you having done yeah I know you
didn't give me a choice so so we've been
doing a little carpool karaoke we've got
the GoPro going bro going did it I'm
gonna draw you an illustration Maxima
drops mic doesn't even but I don't think
we're actually have reconsider can you
tell me at ROS okay I will draw general
with the term this is what I get to be
with the show you're gonna be with the
sure
Oh
I mean this is good there's Jenna with
her Oh Maddy with his churro and me
yelling and mad because he's eating the
churro very actress
Oh
we made Disney the last time I was here
I don't know if I've logged I don't
think I did but I was so we're just
getting here sorry I don't think it's on
the last time that I was so beyond
freezing this time I'm not making the
same mistake I'm wearing a huge winter
jacket
here am i the one
I'm not breathing again
but yeah call my hands you're like a
chair oh you think I'm with the truth
that was like anything I'd love to be
like a churro
for me part seven date well I know but
is it Mickey yeah
there's a way for us out of this cloud
you guys are never gonna believe the hot
Disney dates that we've got today that's
like that's real fresh its new its new
for 2016 what do you think I think I'll
keep it is that heaven that is a M&Ms
covered Rice Krispies strange lovin we
have the Adam since like my birthday
last year last year an entire year this
is tragic it's been way too long here to
you what a nice day
about pop on California screamin and I'm
thinking I might go through it for sure
we've been trying to ride in cyberspace
mountains the last like five times that
I've been here and the line is always
too long when we don't want to wait so
instead we're going to go on the store
look at this well look nice the back
where is it right okay
is that Star Wars sports bra yeah it's
incredible you see how cute it looks on
you oh that looks so nice it's like a
little more like let's get up we have to
get out you have to get out of here too
many good things so hyperspace Mountain
how long was the wing wait is 90 minutes
it's probably worth it but it's so late
already and I know it's up to you do
that and then we just leave oh man he's
a long wait it is a long way I don't
think they're lying General Peter - okay
802 it went out 10 minutes it's now 100
this is a lot then we go home - Mattie
baby boy the time now is 843 we got in
line at no - I don't think it's going to
take us another right up there's nobody
here you know my boss I feel I don't
think I ever posted that vlog but this
is where we lost Buzz Lightyear you guys
remember I posted on Instagram and
Twitter he fell right off in here
we're better for buzz to go sit and
Bennett in beyond within an hour
having the time of my life
that's your joy not interested and then
my friends is our evening at Disney home
link travel Space Mountain hyperspace
mountain amazing no words there are no
no words to describe it
you only weren't to describe it with the
word you just saw in the dark Oh
me and Jenna riding it Wow it was so
fast and so awesome see you guys in the
next vid bye bye this can you even smell
these ice cubes on debt the blueberries
need to be prepped